js
et
elles ont les yeux qui saignent ou
qu'elles poussent des cris
c'est bon 16e blog vidéo j'en ai fait un
presque tous les jours depuis premier
commence à manquer d' un peu tout
complètement les pédales
a los
tainos je cherchais
à voir les personnes tous des cons
si vous êtes attaqués vous devez blé
deux frigos et bien poussé contre la
porte
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez pas l'air d'être toi non
plus mais l'état du sens là je vais me
couper sur quelque chose le recul tu
parlais tout à l'heure moi je parle à
moi-même des fois maintenant
tu as déjà tué quelqu'un
aussi entièrement aussi longtemps que
possible ils finiront tous par mourir de
faim
c'est pas si je suis d'accord avec toi
sur ce point
m
non
et pour ta question du chemin sortir
personne qui survivra ça